more local first responders are joining  in the effort to vaccinate nevada  today clark county fire station 38  hosted a pop-up vaccination event  they held a drive-through clinic  offering the jansen one shot vaccine  as well as the first doses of the pfizer  vaccine organizers say events like this  really help our state take another step  towards normality he's getting back to  normal because of the success of the  vaccination campaign and  we want to continue that we want to  build on that so  we're here when people are ready so some  people weren't ready to go to some of  the mega pods early on  we're now getting more into the  community and making sure that  they have access where they need it a  second clinic will be held at fire  station 38 on  saturday june 12th for more information  on all the upcoming pop-up clinics head  to our website 8newsnow.com